[Musique]
forêt de Bois blanc sain- rose c'est ici
que les Dallons se sont donnés
rendez-vous aujourd'hui pour investir
deux parcelles de forêt dans un seul but
lutter contre une espèce envahissante au
douom
d'acaciaouavier pas la peine d'arracher
parce que c'est pas notre action notre
action c'est ce concentrer là-dessus la
CIA de promotions pour cette opération
une qui vient de la Plaine des Cafres et
une autre du Bernica une journée
d'action sous la direction de plusieurs
partenaires la Direction de
l'Environnement du conseil départemental
avec les gardes des espace naturel et le
Conservatoire Botanique des mascarass
aujourd'hui nous fait nous fait un état
des lieux nous arrache nous compte nous
va savoir là nous connais pas pour
l'instant combien de plans mais a dans
dans les parcelles dans quelques
quelques heures nous va connaître à peu
près combien de plan a combien de plan
va retirer aujourd'hui sur cette zone il
y a sancement de d'acass ul une espèce
exotique qui a été sans doute introduite
par erreur sur sur ce site donc là on
vient on arrache les jeunes PL
arche et c'est parti pour l'opération de
déboisement munis de leur maître d'un
sac poubelle les Dallons partent à
l'assaut de l'acacia premier objectif
repérer la plante
envahissante unu les Pest végétal envah
par tout le pays on arrache pied de
acacia pourquoi on arrache pied d' parce
que ils sont des espèces qui sont venus
d'ailleurs et prenent trop de place pour
savoir plus tard comment on peut faire
pour éradiquer l'espèces là on me
trouve bien parce que là nous sommes un
forêt la Réunion tout ça c'est une
action dans le but civique va dire que
les Dallons des deux
académies Renou avec la nature en
procédant à des prélèvements de despèces
et un recueillement de données qui sera
intégré pour la lutte contre cette
espèce qui s'appelle laacacia une action
qui permet à ces jeunes de se sentir
util sur le terrain avec des
spécialistes ils apprennent à préserver
nos espèces endémiques arracher jeunes
PL des
fois mais maximum cro maisch avant ça
prifère
VO également présent le GP qui à travers
ses associationsre sur espace naturel
sensible du département l'Académie des
Dallons donc le groupe de jeunes vont
arracher donc toutes les les espèces
exotiques envissantes présentes sur la
zone et le gessep donc va faire le suivi
sur le long terme dans un an 2 ans et
cetera pour voir justement le taux de
repousse et voir si l'action a
fonctionné ou pas la cacia une plante
qui peut atteindre plusieurs mètres de
haut les Dallons en ont arraché beaucoup
non un spécimen avec lequel il a fallu
se battre à la pioche mais l'essentiel a
été accompli redonner de l'espace à
notre forêt primaire B au
[Musique]
trophée